la dépression alors vous allez me dire
cette saison mais en fait pas vraiment
parce que la dépression c'est pas la
même chose qu'une déprime saisonnière et
comme la dépression ça fait partie de
ces trucs qu'on a l'impression de bien
connaître alors qu'en fait bah pas
vraiment pas forcément on va refaire un
petit tour de la question allez c'est
parti on va faire comme d'habitude dans
ma série de vidéo sur la santé mentale
si vous suivez un petit peu on va
répondre à une série de questions sur la
dépression pour comprendre ce que c'est
vraiment comment ça marche et comment ça
soigne mais avant de commencer un petit
mot sur inconie qui sponsorise cette
vidéo si vous connaissez pas inconie je
vais vous expliquer ce que c'est mais
avant petite question est-ce que vous
savez ce que c'est un dat broker
euh un courtier en donné ah non là je
non et ben c'est des gens qui récupèrent
nos données personnelles et qui les
revendent bah oui parce que nos données
personnelles on en sème un petit peu
partout sur internet notre identité nos
pseudos nos identifiants et même
carrément notre numéro de CC notre
numéro de téléphone notre adresse
personnelle ce qu'on fait quand on est
sur Internet et cetera et cetera ces
infos les courtiers il lesevendent à des
boîtes qui s'en servent pour faire de la
pub ciblée par exemple mais parfois il
peut y avoir des fuites et c'est comme
ça qu'on finit par se faire avoir par
des arnaqueurs par exemple normalement
on doit pouvoir demander que nos infos
elles soient effacées mais pour ça
faudrait savoir qui les a vous savez
vous moi non et c'est là qu'un conogi
intervient il contacte les courtiers en
données et il demande à ce que nos
données soient effacées et comme les
bases de données ça se revend en
permanence bah il recommenence
régulièrement et tout est automaque is
vous avez rien à faire à part prendre un
abonnement bien sûr et encore même là je
vous simplifie le travail je vous offre
60 % de réduction sur votre abonnement
annuel à incognu pour ça c'est super
simple vous cliquez sur le lien que je
vous ai mis en description et vous
suivez les indications ceci étant dit
c'est parti pour notre série de
questions sur la dépression la
dépression c'est quoi en vrai la
dépression c'est un trouble qui touche
notre santé mentale avant on appelait ça
dépression nerveuse mais clairement ça
rien à voir avec les nerfs c'est un
trouble psychique et c'est loin d'être
rare c'est même assez courant puisque
dans le monde l'OMS estime que la la
dépression touche un adulte sur 20 ça
fait quand même 250 300 millions de
personnes et en France il y a une étude
qui a conclu que entre 2020 et 2021 12,5
% des adultes ont connu un épisode
dépressif et tout ça ça a augmenté de 36
% par rapport aux années précédentes
attention là on parle bien de dépression
on parle pas d'un coup de blouse ou
d'une déprime passagère la dépression
c'est quelque chose qui s'installe
durablement plus ou moins longtemps et
qui modifie profondément notre humeur au
sens psychiatrique du terme c'est-à-dire
en en gros nos émotions et notre façon
de les gérer c'est une vraie souffrance
psychologique avec des conséquences sur
tous les aspects de la vie personnell
professionnel et social vu que nos
relations avec les autres sont
compliquées voire complètement
impossibles pour être très clair la
dépression c'est une maladie donc c'est
pas une histoire de courage ou de
volonté on en a déjà parlé mais ça fait
pas de mal de le rappeler dire à
quelqu'un qui fait une dépression de se
bouger c'est à peu près aussi efficace
que de dire lève-toi et marche à
quelqu'un qui a les deux jambes cassées
et est-ce que vous iriez dire à
quelqu'un qui a une tumeur tu as le
cancer arrête la dépression comment ça
marche alors il y a tout un tas de
facteurs qui entrent en jeu dans la
dépression des facteurs biologiques
d'abord comme une prédisposition
génétique ou des modifications
hormonales qui peuvent arriver avant et
pendant la dépression mais aussi
l'activité de certains
neurotransmetteurs qui peut être modifié
par la dépression vous savez c'est les
substances chimiques qui permettent à
nos neuron de communiquer entre eux et
ça ça a un impact sur plein de choses
comme le sommeil la libido le plaisir
les émotions et cetera et cetera bien
sûr il y a aussi des facteurs
psychologiques et ceux qui dépendent de
ce qui nous entoure des événements de
notre vie et cetera parfois la
dépression elle peut arriver après un
événement traumatisant par exemple comme
un deuil une rupture amoureuse une
agression un accident ce genre de truc
mais pas forcément parfois c'est quelque
chose de plus insidieux aussi être lié
au stress dont on est victime à une
espèce de sentiment d'échec global qui
s'installe petit à petit et puis ça peut
aussi être quelque chose de plus profond
quelque chose qui est lié à notre
personn alité au sens psy du terme
c'est-à-dire à notre construction
psychologique à la manière dont on
fonctionne si vous voulez et puis ça
peut aussi être un mélange d'un petit
peu tout ça évidemment comment on sait
qu'on fait une dépression bah oui c'est
super important de connaître les signes
pour être capable de repérer si
nous-même ou une personne proche de nous
est en train de faire une dépression
déjà faut savoir qu'il y a plusieurs
niveaux de dépression plusieurs degrés
si vous voulez elle peut être légère
modérée ou grave et il y en a plusieurs
forme aussi j'avais déjà fait une vidéo
sur la dépression dans laquelle Jean
Massier racontait très très bien ces
signes à lui je vous ai remis le lien
dans la description si vous voulez aller
voir donc c'est différent selon les
individus mais quand même il y a un
certain nombre de signes bien identifiés
qui doivent nous pousser à nous poser
des questions déjà il y a ce qu'on
appelle l'humeur dépressive qui se
caractérise par une vision très négative
du monde qui nous entoure en général et
de nous-même en particulier un
pessimisme une anxiété une tristesse
comme ça qui nous quitte jamais vraiment
avec en plus souvent cette espèce d'état
dans lequel on est plus intéressé par
rien plus rien ne nous procure de
plaisir on appelle ça la perte de l'élan
vital voilà donc ça c'est la c'est la
base mais il y a aussi d'autres signes
un petit peu plus précis des troubles du
sommeil souvent des insomnies plutôt en
fin de nuit avec par exemple des réveils
très très tôt le matin sans pouvoir se
rendormir des troubles de l'appétit
souvent avec une perte de poids une
fatigue dès le matin avec tout le reste
de la journée une espèce de
ralentissement général qui se répercute
sur notre façon de parler notre façon de
marcher notre façon de bouger notre
façon de penser et cetera une angoisse
quasi omniprésente dès le réveil aussi
des difficultés à se concentrer des
troubles de la tension des troubles de
la mémoire et dans les cas les plus
graves des idées suicidaires qui vont
avec cette espèce de sensation que la
vie ça vaut pas la peine d'être vécu
alors attention on n pas forcément tous
ces signes quand on fait une dépression
on estime que si on a l'humeur
dépressive plus ou moins la perte de
l'élan vital et au moins quatre des
signes dont je viens de parler on peut
commencer à parler de dépression alors
je suis d'accord ça paraît un petit peu
compliqué comme ça mais de toute façon
c'est pas à nous de poser le diagnostic
déjà parce qu'on est pas qualifié et
puis en plus parce que on n pas objectif
vu qu'il s'agit de nous-même par
définition donc si vous repérez
plusieurs trucs dont je viens de parler
là allez consulter votre médecin la
dépression ça se soigne oui ça se soigne
c'est même important de s'en occuper
parce que le risque si on fait rien
c'est que ça s'aggrave ou que ça
devienne chronique c'estàdire que au
lieu que ce soit juste une fois comme ça
bah soit ça devient notre état de base
soit ça se calme mais ça revient comme
ça régulièrement et puis une autre
raison d'aider quelqu'un qui fait une
dépression d'avoir un traitement c'est
que la dépression ça multiplie par 30 le
risque de suicide c'est pas pour faire
flipper he évidemment c'est pas
systématique mais c'est pour vous dire
que quand même ça mérite de prendre les
choses au sérieux si ça touche quelqu'un
proche de vous parce que la personne qui
est concernée elle a pas forcément la
force les ressources l'énergie et cetera
pour impulser les choses elles-mêmes et
puis une autre bonne raison d'aller chez
le psy c'est que les traitements ils
sont efficaces à plus de 70 %. oui aller
chez le psy parce que le traitement
c'est avant tout la psychothérapie donc
un suivi régulier avec une ou avec un
professionnel et puis bien sûr mais ça
vous connaissez il y a les médicaments
les antidépresseurs les anxiolitiques si
besoin attention les médicaments il ne
guérissent pas de la dépression ils
soignent pas la cause ça c'est la
psychothérapie qu' fait mais ils
atténuent les symptômes ils les rendent
plus supportaable au quotidien et ça
c'est quand même déjà super important et
en plus la conséquence c'est que ça
permet d'avoir la force de suivre la
thérapie justement on en a déjà parlé
c'est un petit peu comme quand vous vous
faites une entorse vous pouvez avoir
besoin de prendre des antidouleurs ça va
vous permettre d'avoir moins mal ça ça
va faciliter votreéducation ce qui va
faire que vousz les guérir plus
rapidement et plus efficacement et que
ça va éviter de recommencer et bah
prendre des antidépresseurs c'est pareil
ça peut vous permettre d'être en
meilleures condition pour suivre une
psychothérapie si on veut résumer les
trucs importants à retenir c'est la
dépression c'est une maladie c'est pas
une histoire de volonté si vous avez des
signes ne traînez pas allez consulter et
le plutôt sera le mieux et puis soyez
attentif aux gens autour de vous parce
qu'on n pas forcément la force d'aller
consulter de soi-même quand on fait une
dépression voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien